[Music]
brendan o'neill
editor at spiked host of the brendan
o'neill show welcome to the dark horse
podcast
how are you my friend i'm good how are
you bro i'm doing pretty well
so it's been a long time you and i had
uh we had a very good conversation
on your show a couple of years ago and
we had planned to uh
to meet on this side of the pond and
then uh kovid hit
and uh interrupted our plans to meet so
we're gonna do this remotely which is
the new face to face
sounds good to me so how have things
been
things have been good um well
personally things are fine politically
things are completely and utterly
screwed up
um you know the thing that i've found
most surprising and shocking
and disappointing about the current
moment or the past few months
is the fact that the covid crisis
has exacerbated all the trends and
ideologies that people like you and i
are worried about and i thought it might
have the opposite effect
i thought a genuine threat to health or
you know a serious problem facing
societies might galvanize people to
focus on things that are actually
important like health the economy
ensuring that everyone has a good life
and make them forget all the
nonsense and crap that they'd been
spouting for the previous five to ten to
twenty years but it's had the opposite
effect all that stuff
seems to have intensified over the past
few months which i think is
very disconcerting well i think it's
part of a more general pattern
i think we've seen many events that
could have galvanized us but that
there's something
in our system that causes these
opportunities to be
missed automatically and for us to
descend
further into madness which um is a
pattern we need to notice but we
certainly saw it
with 911 we saw it with
katrina over here in the u.s
certainly with covid the possibility
existed but
was quickly lost and so anyway we seem
to be as you point out just hurtling
faster in the same direction and uh
the disaster that will arise is uh
completely predictable if not with
precision certainly with a certain
degree of
of accuracy so uh what do you make of it
why
why do these potentially galvanizing
phenomena
result in uh further derangement
i think um i think people struggle to
make sense
of dangerous things at the moment i mean
you you mentioned 911 that's a very good
example of this because
in a different era an attack like that
might have been understood
in a political way um as
you know a specific threat a threat that
needed to be dealt with from a group of
people who needed to be dealt with
it would have been viewed primarily in
that fashion
but what happened with 911 in the
current era when it happened
is that it unleashed or intensified all
the backward
reactionary deranged trends that had
already been gathering pace i mean the
very clear example of that is conspiracy
theories
which very swiftly took over from
rational discussion in some quarters and
we were suddenly led to believe that
george bush did this not al qaeda israel
was probably involved in all these other
theories that floated around
in the absence of a framework through
which to make sense of these kinds of
events
and the absence of a framework at work
or the absence of a shared common
outlook or a common language is often
the um
i i think is the starting point of the
derangement
of the current moment and particularly
in the aftermath of something like 911
and of course
there was also a lot of the politics of
fear um
there was a panic there was
authoritarianism there were very
various illiberal laws not only in the
us but in the united kingdom too
in terms of spying on people restricting
what you're allowed to say
um and so on and so forth so it's very
i find it very interesting the way in
which world events or problematic events
or
threats to our societies
the thing we seem to struggle with is is
finding
a common way to understand them and talk
about them and instead
it fractures very quickly and you have
these competing claims as to
what is the real origin of this event
what is the real meaning of it what's
the real impact of it
i think with covid what i find quite
striking about
the covid situation is that i think
um it was less the threat from covert
that
intensified the derangement and more the
lockdown
because what the lockdown we had a
lockdown in the united kingdom it was
supposed to be for three weeks it ended
up being
closer to four months um of course there
were lockdowns in europe there were
various forms of locking down in
different american states
and what the lockdown did it
intensified the atomization of people
it complete in the united kingdom
context it completely broke
up the public there was no longer any
existing public instead we were all
scared individuals
at home whose only duty was to wait for
the daily government announcement on how
bad this disease was
how many people had died and we were
just all watching the death tolls and
listening to the horror stories
no connection with others no democratic
sphere
parliament was suspended the right to
protest was
outlawed there was no way in which
people could come together to discuss
things or talk about things and i think
in that
moment when the broker when the public
was completely
broken up and any sense of collectivity
was completely undermined
we saw the intensification of
particularly that very atomized
individuated
culture of identity of
a sense of victimhood of people
people just conceiving of themselves as
a broken down identity one identity
group versus another identity group
those were the things that intensified
most during the lockdown period and i
think it's fascinating
that the lockdown only really ended in
the uk anyway
with the black lives matter protests
which was really an explosion
of identitarian politics an explosion of
what i would consider to be regressive
politics a very destructive illiberal
censorious moments statues were torn
down statues were defaced
comedy shows were banned um people were
forced to take the knee and if they
didn't they were humiliated in public
ritually humiliated for days on end so
it was
striking to me that lockdown only came
to an end with this incredibly
physical manifestation of the
identitarian
regressive politics and i think that
really demonstrated to me anyway
that the thing that intensified during
the lockdown moment was
primarily the the cult of identity which
i think is going to get worse and worse
so uh if i understand you correctly
you're saying
that the atomization of
uh our collective sense being broken
apart physically from each other
resulted in an obsessive focus on
identity because the things that tend to
blur that line
are connections to other people whose
identity may be related
but isn't the same so i see a lot in
that
on the other hand there's certainly
something to be said
for the fact that people have over time
innovated new modes
and you know as much as
zoom is lacking for example
in some of the face-to-face sense people
have defaulted to it and so i see
simultaneously people being atomized and
also people coming together in ways that
they were reluctant to
before not maybe that because there's no
meaning of physical proximity anymore
due to the fact that we are you know
even if we're down the street from
somebody we may still
do a conference call with them that that
may um it may allow us to choose
too much who it is that we're
interacting with so that we may
or at least some of us may default into
finding people whose identity is very
similar
and therefore creating um
identitarian echo chambers
yeah i think that's very true and um
it's like you know social media and
these other technological breakthroughs
are a double-edged sword in a way
in the sense that they allow us to
communicate in ways that our ancestors
could only have dreamt of i mean you
know it makes the
it makes the printing revolution of the
15 and 1600s look like a
minor affair the fact that pretty much
anyone on earth who has a mobile phone
can publish his or her views
instantaneously
with no need for an editor no need for a
priest no need for a politician to tell
them what they may or may not say
although social media the social media
oligarchs are now taking over that role
increasingly and are now saying
there are certain things you can't say
publicly but
that's an incredibly radical moment the
internet revolution was an incredibly
radical moment unprecedented in human
history and that's
all to the good but what's happened i
think with technology in particular
is that it has molded itself around
cultural trends that were pre-existing
and so i'm always reluctant to engage
in technological determinism i don't
think
technology makes us the way we are
in some instances in some historical
moments that may well be the case but i
think
most of the time technology we kind of
get the technology we deserve as a
society so you know in
earlier periods the technology was
you know ships that were capable of
traversing entire oceans because
that moment was one of exploration and
daring and
the expansion of human knowledge or the
technology might be
splitting the atom and nuclear power or
the space race and various other things
which tended to reflect
a sense of aspiration a sense of
ambition a sense of desire amongst
sections of humanity
what we increasingly have today is
technology that's that allows us to
live in our bubbles which which allows
us to
to naval gaze um to self-reflect to
express
our identitarian impulses in a public
way
and to as you say create echo chambers
and reinforce our existing views and
protect
ourselves in many ways from ever being
confronted with opposing views
technology is now very good
at protecting the individual from
exposure to
contrasting viewpoints contrasting
political ideas and so on
so the great irony i think in modern
technology particularly
online is that it creates the lonely
crowd phenomenon we're all
you know there was a lot of talk about
the internet reconstituting the public
and possibly even
constituting a global public but we all
engage with it
very much as atomized individuals
expressing our own
identitarian ideas or our own sense of
self
into the void essentially and i think
what technology has done it's it's
shaped itself around the kind of
regressive trends that had been taking
hold for
the past few decades and i think one of
the striking things about the covid
period is there was
a lot of connection people did try to
make connections during the lockdown
in the uk for example there were lots of
local groups who were doing shopping for
people and looking after the elderly
there was one where i live and i was
involved in that and people
really did want to have a sense of
taking some collective responsibility
for their
fellow citizens but the speed with which
that got pushed aside by all the old
rubbish i thought was so striking so
very quickly the
the pandemic was racialized for example
we were told
it has a disproportionate impact on
black people and
south asian people which may be true
for various reasons but it was the
intensity of the racialization and the
way it was
folded into the victim narrative i
thought was very striking
um of course we've seen the rise of
censorship there are now certain things
you're not allowed to say about covid on
youtube or on twitter
and other platforms um and
and as i say the explosion of uh
identity politics which i think
really reached its crescendo after the
murder of george floyd
so that's what i found depressing about
covert and very
interesting about the moment we live in
there was a collective impulse there
were people saying
we have to pull together but they were
conquered by
the continuing assertion of the
regressive trends of our time
and i find that quite worrying well if i
can
hunt around in that formulation for
maybe a slightly different one you say
we tend to get the technology that we as
a society deserve
i'm reluctant about this because you
point out uh
you know ocean-going ships and the age
of exploration for example
uh well that brought smallpox
and conquistadors to the new world and i
can't say that there's anything that was
going on in the new world that
uh suggests that they deserved that it
was just sort of an arbitrary
consequence
of um a new capacity to travel
on the other hand i think what you're
saying is
that there's an amplifier
which takes our characteristics and
increases their amplitude to an
extraordinary degree
and one of the places that i see this
happening
is you know covet occurring at this
moment
and interfacing with the identitarian
politics seems to have brought
the dumbest version of marxism that i
think the world has ever seen
which you know is saying something
because there have been quite a number
of very dumb versions and i i say this
with some trepidation because i know um
that at least last time we spoke
you regarded yourself as a marxist of
the
trotskyian stripe which i know is a very
different
version it's a very different view but
nonetheless what we are seeing
at the moment is almost like social
marxism
and you know this has been said by
various people in various ways
obviously jordan peterson has
called it cultural marxism but i guess
the point is there's something about
like it's a marxism of opinion
that has downgraded leadership
and supplanted it with like a
spitballing session
in which no idea is too stupid to be
eliminated from the group does that make
sense
yes that does make sense um you know one
of the
one of the things i am most unpopular
for is
um i'm all i always feel uncomfortable
with
the description of the current political
trends as marxism
um and that's not because i think we
have to defend marxism as this kind of
pure
thing from history which was wonderful
and unquestionable and
you know never let it be sullied or
anything like that my view is that
marxism is done and dusted as an
ideology
it had some good ideas it had some bad
ideas and it didn't work
and so i'm pretty happy that to say that
that is part of history and
i don't think that politics is coming
back and what makes me uncomfortable
with
um the use of that word to describe
what's going on at the moment the point
i often make to
um right-wing friends of mine or
anti-communist friends of mine you don't
have to be on the right to be
anti-communist by any stretch of the
imagination
the point i offer make to them which
infuriates them i have no
doubt is that um if it's marxism
you're worried about you should actually
be delighted by the rise of identity
politics because
i see identity politics in particular
but also
the politics of environmentalism which
is an even more
controversial claim i see those two
forms of politics
as pretty hardcore proof
that marxism as a project or the left as
it was traditionally constituted
no longer really exists because
those two things identity politics and
green politics those two things in
particular seem to me to run so
obviously counter to what the left was
traditionally about
so in the round the left was about
collectivity it was about class in
particular
it was about what we had in common
workers of the world unite to use an old
slogan it was about common bombs
it did not obsess over race and gender
certainly as it progressed through time
it started to see those as
minor details in the broader necessity
to unite
people according to their class
interests
so it was about collectivity on the one
hand and it was about
progress and growth on the other
and if anyone reads karl marx's writings
about thomas
malthus thomas malthus was the notorious
late 1700s early 1800s population
theorizer who said that there was not
enough food
to feed the world and we would all
starve to death
he failed to foresee the industrial
revolution because he was a pessimist
and did not believe that mankind would
be
capable of something like the industrial
revolution so he was completely wrong
and marx's writings on malthus are very
interesting because he
says the problem with this politics is
that it naturalizes poverty it's
it's a libel against the human race
because it presents poverty as a natural
thing whereas the left's belief
is that poverty is a function of
an unequal society and therefore can be
overcome by changing society
so you know a very rough estimation of
what
marxist left-wing politics used to be
about would be to say that it was about
collective bonds and um the the progress
of society through
economic growth and
both of those things strike me as being
completely absent from the contemporary
left so they have no interest in
collectivity they're very much
obsessed with group identity it's an
extraordinarily divisive
movement it's very very fragmentary so
not only is it black versus white but
it's now black versus black where you
have the debates about
colorism and how light-skinned black
people have it better than
dark-skinned black people um the gay
movement is now split apart by the
the rise of the trans ideology um
white women are constantly told by black
female campaigners that they have lovely
lives and they've sold their souls to
the patriarchy so it's it's a
divisive movement but the one that
becomes more divisive
all the time so i don't see that as
being a collective
form of politics in the way that the
left traditionally was
and of course the contemporary left is
very very down on economic growth
um you know they idolize people like
greta thundberg
and her rather doom laden message about
the dangers of economic growth and the
need to stop economic growth which is a
very easy thing for
an upper middle class schoolgirl from
the north of europe to say
i'm sure the three billion people who
still live in poverty would have a
different
point of view so this is the thing that
kind of loses me friends sometimes
because they think i'm defending marxism
but i'm not what i'm
what i'm more interested in what's is
what's new about today
and what's different and i think
sometimes we fall back on
the language of the 20th century to try
and negotiate
negotiate our way through the very
strange
unpredictable 21st century
and i think that can end up making
things
even more confusing than they are that
makes sense oh it does
um the the tragedy of the moment is
really incredible because
you know as you point out for some
reason there doesn't seem to be a
vibrant left
that which takes the mantle of the left
is regressive at best and
really i think manifesting a kind of
collective psychosis
that isn't doesn't belong on any
reasonable
political map it's just vindictive
and insane
but at the same time we know a great
deal now
about what could
work if we could find ourselves driven
collectively
to seek it in other words i think we can
say a great deal theoretically for
example about
why marxism is such an attractive idea
but devolves in one of two directions
inherently um and
in light of that we can move on from
it it's a very um as you say it's uh
well you didn't exactly say but we can
consign it to the dustbin of history as
an experiment that's now been
run enough times that we know these
things and we could seek
um frankly a very different kind
of forward-looking
plan for humanity in other words i i
think
in some sense what has kept us stable
is a tension between left and right
because it was the best regulator we
could come up with that both left and
right
are prone to excesses and the best thing
we could do to modulate them
was allow each one to control the other
enough that we didn't fall off either of
the
two cliffs that they suggested but we
can do better than that
now we now understand uh where we
are we understand ourselves um enough
that we can explore the question of in
light of
the values that most of us share
what system is it that realizes those
values
at the highest rate with the least
carnage and we could pursue it which
you know that's you could hear that as a
collectivist
idea you could hear that as an attempt
to
to liberate individuals and it is in
fact both
but the sad thing is we won't do it
because at some level
we're too busy bludgeoning each other
online
over arguments that frankly to me
all look dead yeah i think
that's a very good description of where
we're at at the moment and i think um
i see us i think we're living through
the death rattle
off the end of left right politics we
haven't escaped
the ripple off the falling apart of that
political system because
you're right you know left right was the
balance through which
almost everything was understood for a
very long period
of time really from the french
revolution onwards when they split
the revolutionary parliament between the
left side and the right side
um political life was governed by that
global affairs was governed by that
there was the west there was the east
and within countries themselves people
were split along similar lines and
institutions emerged which gave
expression to that divide
working men's groups conservative
associations republican groups etc etc
um so when that falls apart or when left
and right loses its
meaning or loses its direction i think
that has a knock-on effect which is
still being felt and if we you know
lots of people talk about the end of
left and right particularly
at the end of the 20th century when the
with the fall of the soviet union and
the knock-on effect that has on
left-wing parties across the west who
kind of become pretty pointless at that
stage
i still think we're living through the
the aftermath of that
falling apart and we're still struggling
to find a new language through which to
make sense of
humanity's needs and how they might best
be pursued
and best enacted i think what we've
ended up with it
often is a left-right politics which is
very much a pantomime
um a shouting match uh it doesn't have
any of the substance or the si or the
seriousness of what it did in the past
you have right-wing panto villains who
are
looked upon as just evil everyone's the
new hitler
according to the kind of infantile left
who
have no understanding of how much they
are engaging in holocaust relativism
when they compare everything that
happens today with what happened
in the 1930s um and the right is guilty
of this too the right will
you know there are some right-wing
libertarians in the us who i meet
who think that any form of collective
politics is basically leninism you know
they will tell me that the national
health service in the uk i have many
criticisms of the national health
service but they think
even collectivized health is essentially
the russian revolution
you know and so they engage in that kind
of um
pantomime politics too without stopping
to think about
the substance of what they're saying i
think one of the most
striking things about today and it's
really worth thinking about this is the
extent to which
the left has become like the right
used to be um in this uh and i mean a
particular form of the right if you go
back to the
20th century particularly the kind of
mid-20th century
um there were sections of the right that
were very um
shrill illiberal censorious
i'm just about old enough to remember
when the people who wanted things banned
tended to be right wingers they tended
to be
conservative christians they tended to
be people who
who literally could not sleep because
they were so obsessed with
pieces of art like um piss christ for
example
um or who wanted to ban any exhibition
of art that was
lewd or salacious or grotesque
um one of the first things i did when i
was very young
i got involved in a campaign to defend a
computer game
launched in the uk the computer game was
called carmageddon
and it was basically a game which
allowed you to drive your car around and
kill people and mow them down and it was
very bloody and
actually very good fun and so on and
the people who wanted it banned were
conservative christian right-wing lobby
groups
and that was really the last hurrah of
their movement that's kind of the mid
90s
and today you fast forward to today and
the people who are at the forefront
i think some on the right still favor
censorship
but the people who are at the forefront
of the new censorship or the or the
desire to ban anything any piece of
culture or any piece of entertainment or
any individual
like brett weinstein who doesn't fit
their mold
the people at the forefront of that tend
to be ostensibly left-wing people
ostensibly radical people
who now act and speak very much like
those kind of
helmet-haired christian ladies who
wanted to ban
everything that offended them in the
20th century so
that shift is also very interesting
and it speaks to how disorientated
political life in the west has become
and i think one of the great challenges
of our time is not simply to confront
this regressive politics every time it
expresses itself
as a kind of um that's quite a defensive
mechanism i think it's important to be
defensive and to
to fight them every time they raise
their heads and and say or do something
dangerous
but at the same time we have to start
developing a language
and a politics that is capable of taking
us beyond
um the left right pantomime
and into an era in which people can give
expression to their viewpoints in a way
that makes sense and in a way that could
impact positively on human life and i
think the discovery of that new
political language is something that is
still
wanting and i think it's something it's
worth thinking about
yeah this is uh very much in keeping
with with what i'm seeing
which is we have what we need
to reinvigorate the discussion and
have a new landscape of possibilities
that weren't
accessible to us 40 years ago
but the irony is we can't get there
because somehow
people who have no idea what it is they
are
actually advocating have veto power over
the discussion
and so you know the
the people i see as representative
of high quality left thinking are
typically
categorized as on the right in order to
dismiss them
which leaves the left nominally under
the control
of people advocating things that very
frequently when i hear
these formulations i feel like it would
take
adults 10 minutes of discussion
to figure out why these things don't
work
can't be tried and to just
put the ideas to bed but instead we're
going to take apart civilization
in order to run an experiment the
outcome of which is
absolutely certain so
something about the veto power which is
obviously in part the result of
an empowerment that comes from social
media
um i i have mentioned to others that i
think
we are suffering the consequences of
um the loss of the role of leadership
that leadership
has been demoted to the status of
influencer and that the problem is
influencer
is a producer consumer
modality and the consumer is at the
point that a leader
might tell you something that you don't
want to hear but you need to know
a an influencer may say it and people
will switch to some influencer that's
less likely to cause them angst
and that that that loss of leaders is
resulting
in you know just the most
foolish beliefs rising as if
they are new as if they have
meaningful content as if they can even
be spelled out
in some sort of consistent form that
would allow you to evaluate them when
really
in each case they run through your
fingers like water
i i think the the crisis of leadership
is actually key to a lot of this because
the thing that is is very striking
is um you know a lot of the kind of the
woke mob
or all these these gangs of social media
vigilantes who go after anyone who says
something disagreeable
you know they they are quite scary in
the sense that they are obviously
unhinged i mean there's a real
problem here i mean they're they're
often quite hateful individuals
i get the most obscene emails from
people like this
threatening things and saying things
which
are really objectionable um and they
behave in a very very bad way if you
look at
um jk rowling for example who's getting
a lot of
abuse at the moment because she believes
in biological sex which is
blasphemy in in the woke era
you know they do things they send her
pornographic pictures
or if she posts a tweet about a
children's
book and lots of children respond to her
these people will post pornographic
pictures in those discussion threads
this is not normal behavior this is
unhinged
regressive incredibly anti-human
anti-social behavior so they are
sometimes quite scary but but the other
striking thing about them is that they
they're often very small in number so
when i've encountered controversies on
at british universities where there have
been groups of people
protesting against a visit of mine for
example
you know it's they're always fairly
small in number
they're always quite socially awkward
strange
young people uh you know we're not
talking about
vast numbers of well-adjusted
human beings so the question i always
ask myself is how is it possible
that these mobs of strange people have
such a big influence and i think
you've actually nailed it it's it's the
interplay between
the um the vociferous nature of these
people and their sensorious desires it's
the interplay of that
with the crisis of leadership and with
the crisis of institutions
and i think one of the main players in
the current climate is
institutional cowardice the way in which
institutions just
roll over as soon as seven people
write them an email saying you know take
down this
monument or rename your um halls of
residence
or uh take down that bust of someone who
died
200 years ago there are so many
institutions who just nod along
and do as they are told or big companies
you know big companies
all it takes is for a handful of people
on twitter
to tell netflix or some other big
company that they are advertising on a
controversial website or they're
advertising on a right-wing magazine
for those in those corporations to
withdraw their adverts
there's so little backbone that you know
no one's willing to stand up and of
course
all of this is just gives a green light
to the mob it feeds
their desires it feeds their sense of
power and so i think there's a really
close
um connection between those two things
and i think the the failure of
politicians
to take a stand against this stuff is
also very striking
you know when trump gave his mount
rushmore speech
recently um on the fourth of july
and he talked about cancel culture it
was actually a really good speech
i have no idea who wrote it i'm pretty
sure trump didn't write it but it was a
really good speech
not very well delivered um but it was a
really good speech and it was so
striking that he
this was the first time a major
politician had said things like this
where he said they want to cancel the
american revolution they want to cancel
the ideas of western civilization and
that's absolutely correct
and so um if more people did what trump
did at mount rushmore
i think we'd probably be in a better
position so
that's a really key point and i think um
what's becoming more and more clear over
time
is that this is an assault on western
civilization
and if you look at the mania of the past
few
weeks in relation to black lives matter
and tearing down statues and everything
else
you know on the surface it looks like an
attack on confederate statues or statues
of slave owners and
you know not many people are going to
lose sleep over a statue of a slave
owner being torn down in bristol in
england
fine who cares but it's not just about
that
this is part of a broader campaign which
depicts
modern western history as one crime
after another
the way in which america is currently
talked about as this disgusting
sinful racist country you know racism is
the original sin of the american
republic which it will never wash clean
and
you know and this conscious effort on
the part of new york times
type people to to change the founding
date of america from 1776 to 16 19 is so
interesting because that's really an
effort by
sections of the liberal elite or the the
illiberal elite to rewrite history
itself to
to refashion america as a country that
was founded in
sin founded in crime rather than one
that was founded in revolution and the
search for freedom and the first
amendment and all those other wonderful
things
the same thing is happening in the uk
the way that left-wing activists and
often school teachers and university
educators the way they talk about
britain
you'd think it was the most evil country
that ever existed
all we hear about is the slave trade and
empire and colonialism and all these
things
which had many many many terrible
consequences around the world no one's
doubting that
we don't hear about the english
revolution we don't hear about the
chartist movement for democracy we don't
hear about the
struggle in the 1600s for press freedom
which
influenced the founding of america to a
large degree we don't hear about the
magna carta we don't hear about
england as the birthplace of liberty in
many ways
so there's a conscious effort on the
part of this emerging elite
to um to re-imagine western history
as just a litany of crimes and i think
that's something
is absolutely essential to stand up to
yeah i resonate with all of this
the cowardice is breathtaking and you
know it's rooted in a very simple
game theoretic comparison between
my ability to get through today in the
face of a mob that's threatening me
and our ability to get through next week
and so what's happening is that
corporations individuals colleges are
all making the same calculation which is
they're solving their today problem
at the expense of a much larger tomorrow
problem
and it is um you you're
a hundred percent right about the attack
on western civilization and the funny
thing is
i remember the moment at which i became
aware of this
during the evergreen meltdown i
detected that this was what was going on
and i
said out loud i believe it was in a
faculty meeting
that not only was this
an attack on the institution but this
this was really an attack
on not only the enlightenment but the
concept of enlightenment
and what came back was not
the denial that i expected it was an
embrace of what i had just said and the
idea was
right enlightenment is a white people
thing
it's bad it is you know the root of
slavery and all other you know sins
and therefore we are right to tear it
down and i just thought my
god what are what are we playing with
here you know we're really
at root dealing with whether we will
have any agreement
that would allow us to establish even a
single claim
on some basis other than power right
you know we saw on twitter very recently
a battle over whether two plus two
actually equals
four and of course that has a history in
literature but the fact that people were
actually earnestly
arguing this tells us where we are
and it has caused me to think the
following
thought i don't think almost anybody is
this dumb
right i don't think as you point out
these are tiny
movements but they're not even it's not
even this tiny number of people who
believes these things i think
almost nobody believes these things and
that in effect they are like
a uniform and they are simply declaring
i am with those people
and the fact is what's frightening is i
am with those people those people may
well have the power to uninvent
the west and if they do
we will be left with tyranny
and then maybe we will reinvent the west
later
if we survive to do it but
the question is really one of net effect
there are obviously major structural
problems
in the west there is a problem with
inequity if we use
the standard definition of that term
rather than the modern fashion
but did the west accomplish vastly more
than it has failed to accomplish it did
and so uninventing it over
that which it has not attained is
lunacy and yet uh
somehow i have to tell you all the
people
with enough wealth to pick up and move
seem to be fleeing cities
because somehow even though there is no
evidence whatsoever that the populace
wants the police defunded
we are now watching the defunding of
police because
we think some mob is demanding it when
in fact
we don't even know you know the mob
because it doesn't have leaders
we can't say what fraction of the people
who are attacking federal buildings
uh actually advocate the abolition of
the police what fraction of them want
police budgets reduced what fraction of
them uh
is simply out to make mayhem but in any
case it isn't civilization demanding
this it is
the tiniest fraction that is now
apparently in a position to dictate
terms to the rest of us
yeah i think um
we are living through a bourgeois
reaction against
the enlightenment and it's terrifying
actually
and um you see it all the time now you
know
the very idea of reason is called into
questions so often these days the
existence of free will the desirability
of freedom of speech
um a belief in
in the autonomy of human beings or the
potential autonomy of human beings all
these ideas that drove
well first the renaissance and then the
enlightenment are explicitly called into
question now particularly on campuses
but in the political sphere
more broadly and um
and and what we're living through is a
reaction against the enlightenment it's
a counter enlightenment movement
made up of various different groups of
people there's the noisy brigade
the kind of woke mob who are the most
explicit in their regressive
backward views um there are the
institutions which are increasingly
incapable of
standing up for the values that they
were founded to stand up for
so you have museums in the uk for
example and museums around the west in
fact
which are now beating themselves up
constantly about what they can put on
display
whether they should send certain
artifacts back to africa or
or back to greece or back to wherever
they might have come from
no sense that they might have a you know
an intellectual responsibility to
uphold the value of the enlightenment
the idea that you could study things
that you could collect things that you
could
improve man's understanding of himself
through
founding these kinds of institutions for
the public good
even at that level the values of the
enlightenment
moment are just being trashed all the
time often by the people who are
supposed to be upholding them
one of the things i find most grotesque
in all of this
is something you've mentioned there
about
the way in which the enlightenment is
seen as a white people thing
um you know that's that's for white
people less for europeans
you know let's talk about what what
black people need or what minority
groups need and
you know apparently they need a form of
politics that is
less based in reason less based in
science i mean we've seen some stuff
over the past few days and weeks
in which ideas like time keeping are
described as a white
trait or a belief in the exercise of
reason
over passion is seen as a white trait
this is explicitly
racist i mean i always was concerned
that woke politics would rehabilitate
racial thinking through
through the identitarian ideology but
it's actually just rehabilitating racism
because if you think white people are
good at keeping to time and
understanding the world in a scientific
reasoned way
black people are not you are a racist i
have news for you you're a racist person
but you know um if you look at
one of the interesting consequences of
the turn against western history and the
turn against western civilization
is the obsession with slavery i think
the contemporary obsession with slavery
is is less an intellectual um
pursuit which is fine of course we
should have historical intellectual
studies of the
slavery period but it's more slavery is
used as a
constant indictment of western
civilization and one thing that they
forget in relation to all of this is the
haitian
revolution in which slaves revolted
against their enslavement
um and created the first free
people's nation uh made up of slaves run
by
made up of former slaves run by former
slaves in haiti who
who liberated themselves what inspired
them to do that
the enlightenment it was the values of
france
and they said to france hold on you have
all these wonderful ideas and values
and you won't let us be part of them um
and there have been numerous movements
through history which have
you know instead of demonizing the west
and saying look how you've mistreated us
for so long what they've said is we want
part
we want to be part of your way of life
and we're going to fight in order to
have that i mean it's the same with the
civil rights movement the civil rights
movement wasn't concerned with saying
america is an inescapably uh
irreparably evil country they put on
their sunday best and demonstrated in
the streets and said we want to have
we want part of the freedom and rights
that you um claim to uphold
so those were incredibly positive
movements and what we have now are just
actually racist or racialist
movements which demonize the
enlightenment demonize reason and
and depict people of color in particular
as being
unfit for that way of thinking you know
one of my just to go back to marxism one
of my heroes is clr
james um a trinidadian marxist who wrote
the black jacobeans which was about the
haitian revolution which is
one of the best history books ever
written um
and he wrote that in the uh early 20th
century
fantastic book everyone should read it
and his point was
he was incredibly anti-colonialist
anti-empire
argued constantly against the things
that britain was doing in africa and
other parts of the world
but his argument was always that the
great crime
committed by those things was that it
deprived
certain people of the benefits of
western civilization
and the benefits of the enlightenment
and his point was always that
you know shakespeare is not just a
writer for british people shakespeare is
is a writer for trinidadian people
shakespeare is a writer for african
people
and that universalist sense that sense
of
that aspiration to be part of a more
enlightened
reasoned freer world which drove so many
movements over the past 200 or 300 years
that's been completely
lost and trampled underfoot by these new
regressive movements which
hate the enlightenment think that black
people are less
capable of autonomy and reason than
white people
and who are doing an enormous amount of
damage
to progressive politics
yeah i i feel like i'm in a good
position to make this point but it never
seems to land
because as a jew
the enlightenment was not a jewish
project i i don't want to tear down the
enlightenment i want to wield the
product of it
like a broadsword and i want to teach
other people to do it
and that's what i was doing at evergreen
when some
ironic protest movement decided to
challenge me as i've
said many times people i'd never met
decided that what i was doing was
illegitimate
um but the basic point is look we've got
two choices here we've got a sort of
harrison
bergeron version in which we tear down
the tool that's working
so well um so that nobody has access to
it well that's not going to work
but that's the plan and the alternative
version
is we figure out how to fully
democratize it so everybody has access
to that tool
but pretending that the tool is somehow
resident in one group that it
fits their their cognitive style that's
garbage that's absolute garbage and it
runs completely a foul of
my experience in the classroom i'll tell
you that much the fact is
we are all built to be scientific and if
you
don't encourage that mode it disappears
in youth but if you do encourage it it
flourishes
and it's you want to liberate black
people make sure that they have access
to math and science and logic
at the highest quality right what is it
that has facilitated
the um continued power of europeans in
the new world is disproportionate access
to these things
so democratizing it has always been
uh the name of the game and somehow
we're attacking everything that sought
to do that including now the civil
rights movement which
is viewed in the most ironic conceivable
terms
yeah uh absolutely and i think
you know even though these movements
these groups these individuals even
though they talk a great deal
about history they're actually
historically illiterate
they have no understanding or
appreciation
of what life was like for most people
prior to the enlightenment and prior to
the industrial revolution in particular
you know life was nasty and brutish
and short and untraveled and
ignorant you know people didn't read
people couldn't read people never
traveled more than
three or four miles from where they
lived and worked they were serfs they
were often owned by other people or
certainly had
incredibly a very little amount of
freedom
you know life was nasty and horrible and
what the enlightenment did by unleashing
the scientific potential
um and by harnessing the scientific
potential
expressly to the aim to the end
of improving human life and improving
human understanding
that brought humanity forward in a way
that had never been experienced at any
other time
the industrial revolution in many ways
um
made good on the promise of the
enlightenment by really utilizing those
scientific discoveries you know as
francis bacon the enlightenment
scientist said he said our job is to is
to
[Music]
tease out all of nature's secrets you
know don't let nature have any secrets
let's really understand what nature is
and how it works
that's what the industrial revolution is
when you um when you tap into
sunlight that has been stored in coal
for
millennia and you unleash it in order to
power
vast new ways of producing things and
transporting things
and it's almost magical it's so it's so
remarkable
and it transforms human life of course
the initial impact of something like the
industrial revolution is that life
becomes
very tough it remains very tough very
short
you know the great cities in the united
kingdom that exploded into existence or
which grew enormously after the
industrial revolution
london sheffield glasgow
these were not nice places to live in
the mid-1800s time
by being in the city working cheek by
jowl
being shoved together people start to
demand the right of their children to go
to school
people start to demand the right of
themselves to have the vote
people start to demand the right to
express themselves to
organize to be political beings and not
just workers
all of that is a knock-on effect of
enlightenment
science reason and industry and
the ignorance of these people who want
to go back to a time in which
the vast majority of humanity worked
tirelessly for their whole lives and
then died at the age of 46.
it's so spectacularly ignorant and it's
often an argument that is made by people
who actually live incredibly comfortable
lives you know it's often
upper middle class people tick-tock
revolutionaries you know the kind of
kids we saw out on some of those black
lives matter
protests you know upper middle class
kids having some fun before they go off
to their ivy league universities
smashing up black
areas which has an incredibly
detrimental impact on the economy
and the livelihoods of the people who
live there and there are quite a few
videos going around showing
black people reprimanding these kind of
upper middle class whites for destroying
communities and destroying local shops
and destroying local police stations
you know these people are historically
illiterate and i think it's really worth
reminding them
of how important these leaps forward for
humanity were
i think you're also right i think
another key aspect of this is conformism
um and you could well be right that
no one is stupid enough to believe this
stuff but
the problem of course is that there are
some things you have to say if you want
to be part of acceptable society
if you want to move in the right circles
if you want to be seen as a good person
you have to put a black square on your
instagram page
to say that black lives matter you have
to take the knee
you have to say that a trans woman is a
woman
you have to say to someone like me when
i ask you do you think a trans woman is
literally a woman
you have to say yes you have to say
these things
because otherwise you risk being cast
out and there's an incredible religious
undertone to this politics where lots of
people say these things
without necessarily believing them it
reminds me i was brought up
catholic and it's absolutely fine to be
brought up catholic i'm not criticizing
that
i know many people who are religious and
who get a great deal from religion
but i remember at the age of 16 and 17
when i was losing my faith i'd be
at mass on sunday saying things i didn't
believe
um repeating things uh in hymns or
or um responses to prayer which i knew
to be untrue and that's the kind of
culture i think we have now on a grander
scale
and a scarier scale in relation to
politics where people
say things that i'm sure they know are
untrue or incorrect
but they feel they have to otherwise
they will suffer the
the salem fate and be sent out into the
wilderness and
and cancelled and i think that's such a
destructive sensorious culture
there's something about it i'm trying to
figure out what the formulation is
but many people have invoked a religious
devotion to these claims and
obviously there's a lot to it but
there's something so juvenile about the
certitude
right in the case of religion i
understand at least
what it is the idea is that this
version of history has been
handed down and you know
in effect treating it as true is
essential
but in the case of any new belief system
there has to be a skepticism about to
what degree
do you have it right you know a trans
woman
is a woman there are obviously ways in
which
we can and probably should treat trans
women
as women and there are other ways in
which we obviously can't
medically for example or when it comes
to
prisons you can't just simply have any
man
convicted of a sex crime let's say
declare himself a woman in order to be
sent to a woman's prison it's
obviously something you have to prevent
for
logical reasons that should be clear to
anyone who spent a minute or two
thinking about it
but instead what we get is
it's like six-year-olds that reach a
conclusion
and then the point is well there's
nothing else to know
i know why this is true and
you know at the very least it is an
extreme version of verificationism
where having seen something they are
incapable of seeing
anything that would contradict it which
means you know as
many of us have said it's the death of
nuance the idea that
people who are incapable of nuance know
anything about how civilization
should be refactored is obviously
crazy on its face but
oh just it seems like
this is the exact moment for
a frankly a
revitalized intellectual left to emerge
it's the perfect moment we have a vacuum
of thinking and we have the basis for
creating a um
a new understanding of how we might make
civilization
more fair and uh we might
further banish austerity right this is
now possible at a practical level it's
not a utopian belief it's just a matter
of understanding
where the waste in the system is and how
to detect the difference between
uh desirable inequality which is part of
what fuels the discovery of
new things and to separate it from
structural inequity which is not
desirable
but we're never going to get there
because at some level we have to fight
with the six-year-olds over whether or
not
um you know all of the important truths
of the world can be summarized
in a sentence that anybody who expresses
the slightest doubt is obviously a
heretic
absolutely absolutely and i think the um
certitude is such a worrying thing i
mean certitude is the enemy of
reason one should always
doubt oneself my favorite painting is
caravaggio's painting of saint thomas
who refused to believe that christ had
risen from the dead until he could
actually
feel the wounds that's really we need
more doubting promises
um we need more skepticism we need
people to question
things things that they are told are
true and things they are told that they
must believe
and um you know
john stuart mill makes this point in on
liberty
one of the key points he makes in on
liberty which is one of the best things
written about freedom of thought and
freedom of speech he makes the point
that the only
justifiable way that you can believe
that you are right
is by subjecting your ideas to as as
public
as debate as possible exposing them to
questioning and criticism and ridicule
and that
will allow you firstly that will grant
you one of the greatest freedoms of all
which is the freedom to change your mind
but also it will allow you to sharpen
your argument to deepen your argument to
make it
clearer to make it more substantial
but what we have at the moment in in the
culture of the echo chamber and the
culture of the safe space
is the precise opposite of that that we
have this pathological
unwillingness to subject our belief
systems to
public confrontation because apparently
that would be a form of eurasia
that would hurt us you know words wound
um you know public debate is now
understood as a form of assault
you know words are akin to violence
that's how it's
seen so everything is done everything
possible is done to protect
our beliefs from any form of challenge
and so of course what happens is that
they become dogma
because if you believe something just
because you know it's right
rather than because you have tested it
then that's not a belief at all it's
it's a dogma
it's something it's rigid it's it's it's
unflinching it's
um it's unreal
so i think the certitude as you describe
it of these
um you know six-year-olds
is really that certitude is a function
of the censorship that they live under
and which they impose on others and
which they uh
the force feel they put around
themselves because they're so terrified
of being exposed
as talking nonsense and the danger you
know so that's bad for them censorship
makes you stupid
that's what it does it turns you into a
child because you
constantly believe that you need to be
protected from ideas so censorship makes
you stupid but it has an even worse
effect on society more broadly
which is it really dulls intellectual
experimentation
and it it really um undermines the
conditions
in which new ideas might be discovered
in which
new things might be discovered in which
a general sense of discovery might be
able to
to flourish um you know
george bernard shaw made this point i
quote it often
um all great truths begin as blasphemies
and that is so true and it's so
important i mean if you think about all
the wonderful things we now take for
granted
the right of women to vote for example
or the right of a man to
have sexual relations with another man
or
the idea that black and white people
should have equal rights
or the idea that um you know the earth
goes around
the sun all these things that we now
take for granted
when people first said those things they
were treated as forms of blasphemy it
was unspeakable in polite society to
express such awful ideas
and it was only through persevering and
it was only through daring
and it was only through people being
brave enough to raise these
possibilities in a world which was not
um
really open to those possibilities it
was only by doing that that we
managed to turn these blasphemies into
truths
because at some level the conditions
existed for people to express those
ideas you know they could
hand out pamphlets they could stand on
soapboxes they could stand up in
universities and
and assert the non-existence of god
which um
shelley did at oxford um in the 1800s
and he was expelled
he wrote a pamphlet on the necessity of
atheism and he was expelled from oxford
for doing so
these days you could be expelled from
oxford for publishing i don't know
a sexist pamphlet or a transphobic
pamphlet or something else
so um at some level the conditions
existed in which people could experiment
intellectually
and express blasphemous ideas which they
believed to be progressive and
interesting
i think the conditions for doing that
have have rarely been
as um undermined as they are right now
it is very difficult now for people to
stick their head above the parapet
if you look at what happens to trans
skeptical feminists on campuses they are
hounded they are harassed they are sent
death threats
if you look at what happened to someone
like mariam namazi the iranian
secularist who is very critical of
extremist
islam she's often hounded on campus
she's told that she is islamophobic
she's told to shut the hell up
or if you look at what happens to people
who who question
climate change alarmism not climate
change but climate change alarmism they
will be called deniers they will be
called heretics
people have suggested setting up
international criminal tribunals because
they say that these people's words
will contribute to the warming of the
planet and the death of humanity
so we live in deeply sensorious times
and the reason that's a problem
is because some of these blasphemies
that people are expressing
will turn out to be correct and will
turn out to be of
enormous benefit to mankind if we allow
them to be expressed and if we allow
other people to
respond to them discuss them and work
out whether they're right or wrong
yeah you have to leave the fringe ideas
uh in a form they can be expressed
because even though most of them are
wrong
the ones that move us forward are
amongst them and this is always i mean
this is
well understood frankly but
it's well understood by people who are
quickly losing their ability
to steer the ship in favor of allowing
children to do it on the basis of a
tantrum that they are throwing
which is i must say just shocking
so let me ask you a couple things we are
obviously facing
an election here in the us in the
context of this
most remarkable uh autoimmune reaction
to reason
and our election looks like i think no
other
in history we have two
candidates who are feeble
for different reasons i mean there's one
shared reason which has to do with age
and they both appear
to show signs of decline although biden
much more so than trump at this point
but nonetheless it is a remarkable fact
and i think
not unrelated to the uh
the tantrum being thrown in our streets
that the same system that delivered us
a choice between two leaders who are
completely unacceptable
um that that same system also
caused an incoherent reaction
to what is the i think
correct understanding that the system is
rigged
this is all one puzzle but nonetheless
it's going to unfold somehow and i guess
the question is
i'm fascinated by the viewpoint of my
friends who don't live here
who are seeing this from afar and you
know i get
genuine alarm from people in the
english-speaking world
outside of the u.s because there's some
i think deep understanding
that the u.s
even if americans lose sight of what's
important
we're not really allowed to disassemble
our own society because of what it will
do to the world
and you know i feel this i feel that the
world has a stake in the united states
remaining coherent
and that in some sense um it is going to
be exposed to tremendous danger
as a result of our collapse if that's
what's coming
how does it look to you uh from the uk
yeah it doesn't look good um
that's the that's my main contribution
to this discussion i mean
sometimes it looks quite shocking um
because
it does raise questions more broadly not
only for the us but for other parts of
the world
about what has happened to political
life what has happened to public life
when seemingly the two
best candidates for the presidential
election in the most powerful country on
earth
are donald trump and joe biden i'm
struck by the age
thing and the decline thing i say this
as someone who
is adamantly opposed to ageism and this
of which i think there is a great deal
at the moment the anti-boomer sentiment
that exists among some of the regressive
groups we've been talking about and
their tendency to understand everything
as a generational warfare rather than
um in in any kind of more complicated
sense
um so i'm against ageism however
if you look at someone like joe biden
i'm actually quite shocked at how
quickly it has become a bad thing to do
if you raise questions about his mental
faculties and people who do that will
often be accused of being you know
alt-right or engaging in right-wing
talking points and raising things that
you should not raise and
but to anyone who watches his
performances it's quite obvious that
he's not
fully in control of his mind in the way
that he presumably would have been
20 or 30 years ago so that in itself i
think is quite
a good metaphor for the decay of
american politics more broadly in the
fact that
these two old blokes seem to be the best
two options for the people to choose
between
and then you have someone like kamala
harris who i just find
actually a little bit creepy
and she's people in the uk
so speaking about other parts of the
english speaking in the world
i think people in the uk often find even
her accent
quite strange um it's one of those kind
of nasal
american accents which is just smacks of
a certain form of privileged existence
and
i often don't understand what she's
saying i know commenting on her accent
is not particularly profound but i think
it is quite
interesting that she has this very
strange distinctive
west coast accent but what strikes me
most about
biden and harris the biden harris ticket
is that they only seem capable of
defining themselves as
not trump um there's so
they're not um they're not whipping up
any enthusiasm
they don't have a huge set of ideas they
don't seem to have
much of a program that they don't have
any particularly inspiring agenda
but they're not trump and i think that's
going to backfire on them because what
it will look like to many people
it will look like the revenge of the old
establishment because
even though i am a trump skeptic i
perfectly understand why so many people
voted for him
um it's because they were tired of the
old liberal technocratic establishment
as personified by people like hillary
clinton and
uh who obviously obviously won a
majority of the popular vote but people
especially in more working-class areas
were
tired of that were not interested in
that and they opted for the man who
posed as an anti-establishment figure
who posed to someone who would stir up
political life who posed to someone who
would
actually listen to them which
politicians had not been doing
and in fact both east coast and west
coast culture in recent years seems to
have become
singularly obsessed with mocking middle
america
mocking rednecks mocking people with
their guns and their bibles and their
backward beliefs
and really sneering at the average
joe as you know unenlightened and stupid
and backward and
everything else so the vote for trump
made sense in that context
if the democrats i know are now going to
go into this election saying we're not
trump
i don't think that's going to work so
the choice i think it's it
it's possibly even worse than you've
just outlined there very well
because it's now an election that is
completely
and utterly revolves around
trump your choice is trump or not trump
your choice is not really even trump or
biden because
who knows what biden is fundamentally or
what he
what he represents he's quite changeable
in his views he
he will often ditch views if he if he
thinks they're not working particularly
well
or if you look at the way kamala harris
justified
the fact that she could roast biden in
public
a few months ago and now be his running
partner she said well it was just a
debate
that's what you do in a debate you say
controversial shocking things
in other words she didn't mean it she
didn't believe it she was posing
it's so incredibly shallow so there's
nothing of substance in the
in the biden harris ticket this really
is a choice between trump and not trump
and that is really
the american people deserve so much more
than that
so the question of how to rejuvenate
american political life
i think is of huge importance to
americans and the world
and i'm not sure how that can be done
other than
pushing the kind of ideas that people
like you have been pushing which is
calling for a return an increased
valuation of freedom
and reason and equality
and focus i think all those things i
think it's important not to see
the push back against wokeness as a
discreet
project i think it's actually something
that can tap into
and bring back to life the broader
public sphere
and re-engage people in a politics of
purpose
and a politics of vision which at the
moment
is sorely lacking in america yeah you're
exactly right
and you know the distaste for trump is
strong in many circles but the
democratic party
has somehow created a world in which the
argument to vote against trump is no
longer
a straightforward one because for one
thing
biden's decrepitude is so severe that
there is at least an argument
that it isn't safe to have somebody in
that condition in the white house
also there's the question of
what the democratic party is partnering
with because it's partnering with this
woke
mob it isn't obvious that the trump
scenario is more frightening
than the empowering of this woke madness
and so you know lots of people i believe
are going to vote
for trump because there's some hope that
if
you know the cities descend into madness
trump will do something
to stop it and you know as somebody who
lives in a city i get it
right it's it's frightening to be in a
situation where suddenly we're being
told that
you know policing is itself racist and
you know in which these city governments
are actually um
going through the exercise of
dismantling
police departments even though like i
said before i don't think there's any
evidence at all that this is a popular
idea it's just a very forcefully
delivered idea from some tiny number of
people who are obviously crazy
so um so anyway yes we've got a
an appalling situation you're right
about kamala harris
she is essentially the
dnc incarnate and
biden is not much different frankly i
think
there is an awareness that biden can't
go the distance and i will
be a bit surprised if he is actually
the person who is who runs
in other words i think there's a strong
chance that kamala is actually to be the
nominee
and that they will swap her into that
role
at the point that the danger of
democracy breaking out
in the democratic convention
is passed but
but in any case right this is
you know whatever you're detecting about
kamala be it
her accent or the fact that what she
says is empty or the fact that the
ticket
itself has no ideas that anybody can
name
there's no enthusiasm about it the only
thing it is is an alternative to trump
and the objection to trump is um
based very strongly in distaste for him
there's no acknowledgement that he was
portrayed
as hitlerian and uh he didn't turn out
to be
hitlerian and there was no rethinking of
anything they just
without skip and a beat continued down
this path so
um yeah it's a very it's a very
frightening situation
now i don't know if you're aware but i
have advanced a
alternative plan for our election
to elect somebody different um
and uh it's interesting
how difficult it is to reach americans
with the very simple idea that when both
parties have
effectively declared war on leadership
and a commitment to politicizing
everything
that extends right up into the
willingness to destroy the nation
over symbolism that we have some
obligation
to try something else people are so used
to living in a world that is divided
red and blue that they uh
have difficulty imagining any other
possibility
yeah i think that's true and um
and i think trump you're right to to see
that to say that trump was seen by many
people as the other possibility
i'm sure some of them still think that
because the democrats have not
improved much and in some ways have got
worse over the past four years
and i'm sure some people no longer
believe that but probably still see
trump as a better choice than
than the democrats i think the um the
point you make there about the democrats
going down this kind of woke
route that's really important because
this is a common theme in in social
democratic parties
across the west what's happened is that
they have transformed
radically over the past couple of
decades they or longer in fact
you know they've shifted away from their
working-class base
um this is happening in europe this is
happening in germany where the social
democratic party got its worst
ever election result um a couple of
years ago
it's happening in other european
countries it's happening in the uk where
the labour party
which is our social democratic party has
been completely and utterly conquered
by woke nonsense and has utterly
alienated its traditional working class
base the the people it was founded to
represent
which is why so many working-class
voters voted for
boris johnson in the december general
election
an unprecedented victory for the
conservative party which now
represents working-class people in this
country
which is you know historically
unprecedented and
there's a similar dynamic in the us
although of course it takes a different
form because
it's a different country but what you
have there is the the democrats
quite openly shifting away from
their traditional voters and embracing
new constituencies
um you know joel cotkin
writes very well about this and so do
other writers about the the
creation of these new constituencies of
the urban
upper middle classes um highly educated
women
um highly educated sections of the black
community
people who live in on the east coast or
the west coast
uh you know people who watch saturday
night live and
and share memes mocking donald trump i
mean these are
the targets now of the democratic party
whereas they look upon their traditional
voters as
racist homophobic well the basket
of deplorables as hillary clinton
memorably put it that is really how they
see these people so
we're witnessing an incredibly important
realignment of political life
where you have left-wing parties
aligning themselves with the kind of
bourgeois sections of society the
well-educated sections of society and
looking down their noses
at ordinary people and then you have
sections of the right and i think donald
trump has done this relatively
successfully
who are real realigning themselves with
the working man the working woman and
saying that they will represent their
interests against the elites i think
that's it's such an interesting shift
and it will be so fascinating to see how
it plays out
in the us this time because i think that
will impact globally
i thought the point you made about i've
thought the exact same thing about the
way in which trump was referred to as
hitler
and then there was no reckoning with the
fact that that wasn't true
i actually think that's a that's an
incredibly serious matter
we had the exact same thing in the uk
there were protests against trump
i went to them to observe them every
other placard had trump with a hitler
moustache
telling us that the 1930s were coming
back
and none of them have um apologized for
doing that
or reassessed the situation
or admitted that they were being
hysterical they've just let it slide
into
history and i think that's unforgivable
firstly because it describes trump in an
inaccurate way he's not hitler
the people who voted for him are not
right-wing fascists
um so they were lying about trump and
they were lying about trump's support
base
but also it is part of this process of
holocaust
relativism which i think is a really
worrying phenomenon
because the more that you compare or
relatively ordinary political events
in the present the more that you compare
those things to what happened in the
1930s the more you
make the 1930s seem ordinary
and mundane and it chips away at the
uniqueness
of the holocaust and it chips away at
the seriousness of that moment
and the fact that this was the greatest
crime in human history
and contributes to the broader um
belief that the holocaust was not
particularly a big deal
the nazis were bad people in the same
way that trump is a bad person
um and that again is another example of
just historical ignorance and historical
illiteracy
and and the terrible consequences that
can have
for people's understanding of the past
and for their understanding of what
certain groups of people experienced in
the 20th century
i think um your idea of um
creating the possibility of another
candidate someone who's not
trump and who's not not trump which is
what biden and harris are
i think that's really interesting and my
view of political life at the moment
is anything that can be done to
open the door to a new possibility is
worth pursuing
um this is why i'm quite interested in
the rise of populist parties
in europe now some of these populist
parties are bad they have
awful beliefs some are good some are far
right some are far left
you know there are all sorts of parties
but what i think is fascinating and
important and quite encouraging about
them
is that they are trying to create
another possibility
something that isn't the conservative
right
right-wing
section of society and something which
isn't the kind of collapsing social
democratic wing of society and that
they're trying to open the door to
something else
all forms of political experimentation
if they are driven by a desire to
democratize public life and to re
to reintroduce reason and
freedom and equality to the heart of
public debate
anything that does that i think should
be welcomed and encouraged
yeah i i agree it must be and
the basis for it being incredibly
vibrant is
there but it is going to be shouted out
of existence before it gets a chance
to uh to actually flourish
now i i agree with your analysis about
the 1930s and the the real hidden danger
here
is that we have robbed the very special
and important claim that something
is hitlerian of all meaning so that as
it returns
we can no longer invoke it and have it
resonate
and i i must say i feel this you know
both
as you know an analytically focused
person who
recognizes that that must be the case
but also as a jew
who knows that you know i'm beginning to
hear a kind of
um commonplace anti-semitism
in this woke ideology that
is so familiar from what i read about
and heard about as a young person
that i know the danger isn't
where we were told it is and it is
exactly in
the hands of those who are shouting nazi
this nazi that
which um you know i guess uh
maybe it doesn't rank given the level of
irony that seems to be attained on a
regular basis these days but it
certainly would be up there under
ordinary circumstances
so i don't know suppose
the u.s does come apart what happens in
europe
well that that's a good question uh i i
think the question is what happens in
the world i mean it's
you know the ripple effect would be
enormous
i think i mean my view is
i don't think america will come apart
but at the moment
i am genuinely shocked at how divided
america is i mean we really are going
through
i mean people compare it to 1968 when
there was lots of
street disturbances and an election and
all sorts of things were going on at the
same time
i think it is like that but in but it's
even more in
incoherent um because at least in 68
you knew what people were doing right
you could agree with them or disagree
with them but you knew why people were
on the streets
um you knew what they were protesting
about some of them were good protests
some of them were bad protests but
it all fitted within a broader framework
of political life
and the question of how to pursue
certain interests and what would
what was the best method for doing that
it made sense
you people could make sense of it even
if they no doubt found it quite
disorientating
i think at the moment the framework is
missing and it's just
there's such an a sense of incoherence
and a lot of the protests
are nihilistic um
they are targeted at abstract symbols or
symbols of america more broadly you know
the footage of people tearing down
statues of columbus for example
and stamping on his head and rolling him
into a river or whatever else
you know that's that that's a terrifying
image because
this is it's like philip roth's book
american pastoral you know it's like the
the upper middle classes have gone
insane
and there's very little sense to this
and
i think what's most interesting about it
quite a few writers have made this
observation
which is that this is not a radical
protest
this is almost the revenge of the
bourgeoisie this is the sons and
daughters of privilege
who are horrified by the way in which
politics has gone particularly over the
past
four years and are taking their revenge
by
raging against america raging against
ordinary people raging against
things they don't like so it's very
strange it's very incoherent it's very
worrying
so i think um i think america will
just about manage to hold it together
but what i think is really clear about
this election
is that whatever happens it won't
stop these problems because neither
ticket has the capacity
to quell this descent or to give
americans
a sense of vision or a sense of
connectivity or a sense of purpose
trump said he would but he's failed in
numerous ways and he hasn't lived up to
the promises he made to
middle america and to working-class
people
byrden and harris i think are only
interested in appealing to a particular
section of society and promoting a
particular
form of woke politics so if anything i
think
you were right earlier to raise the
interplay between the democratic
establishment
and the and the disturbances on the
streets and i think the democrats are
playing with fire in relation to that if
they
think that by implicitly encouraging
these disturbances that it will work to
their benefit
i think they're probably in for a rude
awakening um
but neither camp will be capable of
weaving a new purposeful narrative for
america
so i think that task is ongoing
regardless of what happens in the
election
in a few months time that cannot
i don't think it's possible to
overstate the importance of carrying on
that discussion
about what america is for
what the west is for what values are
important what values we have to rescue
from the savages of campus life and
elsewhere
that discussion is so crucial to the
broader discussion
of how to improve political life and in
some ways it's prior to that
i think it's the kind of work that
people like you and others are doing i
think is actually prior to the
rejuvenate
rejuvenation of public life because it's
only by defending those foundational
principles and those foundational values
and the idea that america is a pretty
good experimental republic which has
done a lot of good stuff for people
it's only by defending those values that
we then might get to a position where we
can
inject public life more broadly with a
sense of purpose so
i see i think two things are going on at
the moment you have
mainstream political life which is a
complete mess
and there's no inspiring figures at all
and then you have this
other battle these culture wars this
clash between
regressive regressive
supposed lefties and ordinary people who
are probably very skeptical of
their aggressive leftism and i think at
some point
those two different strands of american
life will come together
but whether that will happen in the
election or after it i think remains to
be seen
yeah well that's a very good question
and if it um
plays out as you say i only see these
patterns getting worse
over the course of the next four years
and there's a question about how long we
can hold out
as they do get worse because they've
gotten bad at an incredible rate
all right well brendan this is
as always been a fascinating discussion
i hope it is the first of many
um people should find you
at the brendan o'neill show and on
spiked anywhere else
those are the main places yeah are you
still the last person
on earth with no twitter account i don't
use twitter but i
do use instagram so you do use instagram
all right cool um how do people find you
on instagram
my name is burnt oak boy that's b u
r n t o a
k b o y excellent
well thank you so much for visiting the
dark horse podcast
and uh i guess we'll stay tuned and see
what happens in the election
thanks brett all right be well brendan
[Music]
[Music]
you